alors faut-il inscrire le droit de
choisir son genre dans la constitution
comme le proposons luc mélenchon
vraiment nécessaire de le graver dans le
marbre pour être acceptée ou mesure
inutile en attend toujours vos réactions
sur le conte télégramme verte et france
et place au face à face
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler anthony
gratacos secrétaire général de la gauche
républicaine et socialise bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous en direct avec nous
également gens mais si un président de
l'institut apollon bonsoir jean messia
merci de nous accompagner par skype
également pour ce face à face alors pour
commencer une réaction à ce reportage
que vous venez de voir mariko qui
dénonce que le genre soit devenu une
question politique ce sont des
réflexions qui aurait dû rester sociétal
seins dit-elle vous partagez cette
opinion en touche finalement alain team
anthony gratacos oui tout à fait c'est
une question qui concerne chacun dans
son dans son for intérieur dans sa vie
de tous les jours et autant l'état doit
garantir l'égalité pour chacun autant il
n'a pas à se mêler de ce qui se passe
dans la vie privée des uns et des autres
quand on dit l'état doit garantir ça
veut dire quoi on doit le garantir
jusque dans la constitution alors non
pour paraphraser montesquieu est parfois
nécessaire de modifier la constitution
mais lorsque cela est fait il faut le
faire d'une main tremblante la
constitution c'est un texte très
important c'est la loi fondamentale de
la république qui organise nos
institutions et qui édicte les principes
fondamentaux et je ne crois pas que les
revendications sociétales et sa place
est d'ailleurs
inscrire une telle revendication est
légitime et qui existe d'ailleurs dans
la loi c'est déjà possible de le faire
dans la constitution ça changerait
profondément la nature la constitution
aujourd'hui c'est un texte qui parle de
nos droits collectifs et pas de droits
individuels et ce droit individuel est
plus forte dans les pays anglo saxons
par les communautarismes c'est tout à
fait contraire à nos principes
on va en parler justement ces
communautarismes jean-mi siens endroit
pouvoir choisir son genre où il nous est
attribué l'allemand dès la naissance
quel est votre avis
mais je pense que la liberté de changer
de sexe elle existe déjà
la liberté de changer de genre sans
changer de sexe pour moi est
inconsolable
avec cette folie on se retrouve en effet
avec des individus qui ont des attributs
masculins par exemple dans des équipes
sportives de filles où le femme ou qui
vont dans les vestiaires féminins de
clubs de sport qui vont aller dans les
toilettes pour femmes
j'en passe et des meilleurs je pense
qu'il s'agit là d'un délire grandjean
risque avec lequel il faut absolument
arrêter un homme a le droit d'aimer à
mme anne holmes
incontestable et même de l'épousé est
symétriquement pour les femmes mais on
peut pas céder aux desiderata d'ultra
minorité qui ne réclame pas des droits
mais des privilèges exorbitants du droit
commun donc en réalité pour dire aussi
clairement à gauche un beau spectateurs
téléspectateurs c'était que
vous avez un pénis n'a été constatée
dans votre essence vous êtes un homme
vous avez un utérus et a été constaté à
votre et bien vous êtes une femme si
vous vous faites opéré qu'un chirurgien
atteste que vous avez changé de sexe
alors bien sûr vous pouvez changer
d'état civil mais sinon vous restez ce
que vous êtes au moins pour la société
ce que vous sentez dans votre tête c'est
votre affaire personnelle je crois que
on ne peut pas faire la société peuvent
pas s'adapter aux délires individuelles
des uns et des autres je pense que là où
c'est vraiment assez pernicieux c'est
que on parle beaucoup de l'écologie à
juste titre les écologistes ont compris
je dirais part au débat public de
manière très importante et 7 ans et
c'est très très bien mais la première
des écologique écologie humaine c'est à
dire que pas si vous voulez défendre les
droits naturels
d'aider de toutes les spèce à la fois
animale et des espèces d'insectes et
venir nier par une projection de la
pensée humaine ce qu'est la nature
humaine la nature humaine a fait que
laisser homme ou femme mais qu' on a
compris des gens mais si on va vous
évidemment vous redonner la parole mais
on va justement écouter quand même jean
luc mélenchon puisque c'est lui qui a
vraiment mis ce débat sur la table
c'était le 17 novembre m'écoutais je
dis juste que si c'est votre intime
conviction que vous êtes une femme ou un
homme vous avez le droit de l'affirmer
contre la réalité des apparences de
votre corps la société la seule chose
qu'elle peut espérer ce que vous soyez
bien dans votre peau dans votre rôle
dans votre genre celui que vous aurez
décidé anthony gratacos comme le dit
jean messias est une forme de délire ou
comme le dit jean luc mélenchon il faut
que évidemment la société aide les
individus être bien dans leur peau et
leur garantissent justement ce droit
mais ni l'un ni l'autre
c'est un droit qui est déjà inscrit dans
la loi et à partir du moment où ça ne
pose pas de problème à la société dans
son ensemble
je ne vois pas de problème à ce que
quelqu'un change de genre et les
procédures qui sont faites aujourd'hui
qui peuvent être lourdes parce que sont
des sujets qu'il faut prendre quand même
avec beaucoup de précaution derrière il
ya beaucoup de souffrance et jean luc
mélenchon l'a dit dans son intervention
d'ailleurs et il avait raison pour
autant c'est une décision qui est lourde
de conséquences et qui ne peut pas être
prise à la légère mais pas d'accord avec
jean mais c'est quand il dit c'est une
sorte de délire non mais après je pense
que c'est symptomatique
c'est symptomatique d'une dérive
identitaire de la société dans son
ensemble qui correspond pas au projet
républicain français qui se tournent de
plus en plus vers l'exaltation de
l'individu contre le projet collectif et
l'individu en tant que tel c'est un peu
la nouvelle donne et qui emplit le
siècle comme aurait dit malraux et ses
communautés ces groupes d'individus qui
se rassemblent où se reconnaissent via
leur religion parce que là c'est la
question du genre mais en fait ça touche
tout un tas de sujets via leurs couleurs
d'auto leur religion leur pratique
sexuelle ou leur genre sont des danish
de consommateurs formidable pour le
capital c'est plus un problème
capitaliste qui nous a été importé du
monde anglo saxon via les réseaux
sociaux qu'un problème revendicatif en
soi parce que ça concerne très peu de
gens en réalité et c'est pour ça que ça
n'a pas sa place dans la constitution
qui est une règle générale mais par
contre sa place dans le droit civil et
ça y est déjà jean mais ça c'est vrai
que mariko c'est ce qu'elle dit alors
que c'est la première mr tron jeune
candidat à la présidentielle elle
prononce le mot de walk it mais elle a
des mots assez durs
d'ailleurs alors qu' on pourrait
s'attendre à ce qu'elles défendent
justement cette culture web comme on dit
et là il ya une forme de perversion en
substance dit elle
alors je suis d'accord avec ce que c'est
que ce qu'elle dit je suis également
d'accord avec ce que viennent dire votre
intervenants c'est vrai que la première
des identités dans dans un projet
républicain et l'identité nationale le
projet républicain est un projet qui
reconnaît des citoyens ne reconnaît pas
des individus suisse qu'il membres d'une
minorité ou en tout cas autoproclamé
donc évidemment que si vous retirez la
citoyenneté si vous retirez l'identité
vous créez un espèce de désert et la
nature ayant horreur du vide sur ses
déserts vont pousser des ronces
parfois monstrueuse de particularisme
d'individualités qui vont essayer de de
ce grand créer en quelque sorte des
ersatz
d'identité qu'elle soit d'ailleurs
sexuelle des identités de gens des
religieuses désir de 10 ans d'aidé des
identités pardon culinaires et que
sais-je encore quant à jean luc
mélenchon
je pense que
alors même que lui ces prétendus blicain
il est dans un tel déficit des lecteurs
il va racler finalement tous les fonds
de tiroirs diversiterre donnez lui un
peu de temps à jean luc mélenchon il
demandera à l'avortement jusqu'à six
mois pour les faits ministre ultra le
droit de vote pour les céréales et des
chats afin de plaire aux animalistes
l'appel à la prière des médecines
diffusé par haut parleur pour mobiles
pour complaire aux musulmans etc etc
donc je pense que ce genre de message
c'est une caricature je comprends le
sens de la de la proposition de jean luc
mélenchon il sait il souhaite
sanctuariser cette disposition
parce qu'il peut qu'on considère qu'elle
pourrait être en danger aujourd'hui vu
les débats qui traversent notre société
mais je pense qu'il est passé à côté des
conséquences que cela aurait sur la la
la la
constitution elle-même sur la façon dont
elle est composée le changement de
nature que ça entraînerait de là à dire
que dans six mois il proposera le vote
des chiens et des chats ou de je ne fais
quoi il ya quand même un monde entre les
deux en tout cas ce débat mais pas que
leur agite même les instances
européennes la commissaire à l'égalité a
récemment distribué un guide interne
avec la liste de certains termes
proscrit petit aperçu du nouveau manuel
de savoir vivre au sein de l'union
européenne qui a pour l'instant pas été
entérinés parce que ça a ému jusqu'au
vatican écoutez
notre communication ne doit jamais
présumer que les personnes sont
hétérosexuels s'identifie avec le genre
attribué à leur naissance ou s'identifie
de manière binaire écarté aussi
l'utilisation de monsieur ou madame
basée uniquement sur le sexe a signé à
la naissance en cas de doute utilisé mx1
jamais sien on imagine que tout ça ça
vous fait bondir ce guide un qui
d'ailleurs ne remporte pas que les
questions des gens mais aussi de la
chrétienneté un noël et marie serait
proscrit selon la commissaire à
l'égalité elle aimerait qu'on parle de
la période des
vacances de fin d'année au lieu de
parler la période de noël c'est ça qui a
ému le vatican et c'est ce qui bloque
pour le moment ce guide interne ça vous
fait bondir on mélange tout selon vous
écoutez moi je pense que l'union
européenne depuis le début en tout cas
dans le tour lent des années 90 et 2000
agit contre les nations et contre les
identités nationales donc l'union
européenne va promouvoir toutes les
identités alternative qu'elle soit
religieuse sexuelle culinaires et cetera
pour s'en servir comme bélier pour
défoncer en quelque sorte les reliquats
d'identité nationale parce que l'union
européenne s'imaginent que les seul
obstacle à l'émergence d'une identité
européenne qui serait qu'une identité
économique d'une certaine façon et est
bien c'est de mettre à mal les identités
nationales or je suis désolé je pense
que c'est pas ainsi qu'on va amener les
citoyens
des nations européennes à se sentir
européen je constate d'ailleurs que en
même temps qu'elle nie l'existence de
noël l'existence de ces deux 2 de marie
est ce que vous voulez dire elle affirme
également d'autres identités puisque
l'union européenne le demande par
exemple de prendre en ligne de compte
l'émergence de minorités musulmanes de
minorités religieuses etc donc moi
j'étais pour ceux qui militaient pour
l'inscription des traditions judéo
chrétiennes dans la constitution
européenne il est évident que c'est pas
en étant une union hors-sol déracinés en
quelque sorte que l'union européenne va
susciter l'adhésion des citoyens puisque
pour être citoyen eh bien on est
enracinée dans une nation dans une
culture dans des traditions et si
l'union européenne veut effectivement
suscité l'adhésion des citoyens à l'idée
européenne
eh bien elle ferait mieux de cultiver ce
que nous sommes plutôt que de cultiver
ceux qui sont contre nous les certaine
façon anthony gratacos justement son ce
guide interne encore une fois qu'il n'a
pas été validé mais enfin c'est vrai ne
pas utiliser mesdames et messieurs de
manière à ne pas vexer les personnes
intersexe ou cuir c'est ce qu'elle vit
sept comités cette commissaire à
l'égalité noël et marie on en parle le
plus non plus noël le mot et est banni
est ce que ça vous choque est ce que
c'est pas un peu contre productif on
parlait justement l'époque un procès
nadine morano qui voulait mettre dans la
constitution justement les racines
chrétiennes
est ce que justement c'est le même pied
d'égalité où c'est différent pour vous
ces deux aspects pourtant qui sont
mélangés dans ce guide interne européen
bon c'est un document de travail ça n'a
pas encore valeur réglementaire mais je
ne suis pas non plus sur la position de
jean messia les valeurs chrétiennes etc
ont des débats traverse notre société
aujourd'hui on est d'accord on n'est pas
d'accord en tout cas il va falloir en
parler parce que beaucoup de jeunes sont
attachées par exemple à ces débats la
question qui se pose à nous en ce qui
concerne l'europe c'est qu'on a vu par
exemple il ya quelques semaines une
vidéo qui mettait en valeur le port du
voile ça fait ça fait polémique on voit
que la commissaire à l'égalité du monde
voit que l'union européenne la
commission le parlement etc sont
infiltrés aujourd'hui le terme et
est assez juste il n'est pas trop fort
par des lobbys qui sont puissants qui
ont des moyens très importants et qui
essayent de pousser dans un sens ou dans
un autre et la réalité c'est que ceux
qui défendent aujourd'hui les valeurs
universelles les valeurs républicaines
ceux qui cherchent à défendre un projet
européen d'émancipation des peuples eux
ne mettent pas les mêmes moyens ne sont
pas aussi nombreux et ne font pas autant
de lobby et il va falloir que le
l'ailé gauche européenne au lieu de se
perdre dans des combats minoritaires et
identitaire comprennent qu'aujourd'hui
on est en danger sur ces questions et
qu'on est attaqué de toutes parts à la
fois par les islamistes à la fois par
les identitaires d'extrême droite etc il
falloir qu'on se réveille pour imposer
notre point de vue
merci beaucoup en tout cas tous les deux
d'avoir été avec nous en tenir à ta
conjointe messia d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir et avant de se quitter je
voudrais